reunimos a siete pares de gemelos somos
gemelos somos gemelas somos gemelos los
gemelos
somos gemelas
una pareja de gemelos es falsa si el
grupo descubre quiénes son se repartirán
un premio en efectivo
si los falsos sobreviven ganarán todo el
premio
quiénes son los impostores
quienes son gemelos y quienes son
mellizos somos gemelos mellizos somos
mellizos mellizos gemela todos lucían
bastante diferentes no fue como todos
eran gemelos y será fácil de adivinar
digamos nuestro signo zodiacal al mismo
tiempo empezar estaremos de acuerdo 3 21
14 30 21 leo
nadie es geminis bien
inmediatamente pensé que era andy
samberg hambre this se veían menos
similares podría mostrarse y ni siquiera
nos parecemos no se puede decir mucho
porque
cuando mi mamá llamo a mi papá y le dijo
que iban a tener gemelos él estaba tan
conmocionado que dijo que no eran suyos
nuestros madres lloraron y cuando
averiguaron que les dijeron está bien va
a ser una niña entonces el otro bebé
también será una niña y
hay otros gemelos en sus familias
honestamente fue muy difícil saberlo
porque todo el mundo estaba siendo muy
respetuoso todos tuvieron la oportunidad
de pensarlo con tiempo apenas y pudimos
decir algún cumplido y ya debíamos votar
tal vez viendo cual par no tenía mucha
química y otros que supongo que no
tuvieron la oportunidad de hablar tanto
fueron un poco menos asertivos pero hubo
algunos que se destacaron como gemelos
de inmediato
[Música]
[Aplausos]
me lo esperaba yo estaba como vamos
creando creo que si hubiéramos pasado a
otra ronda nos habríamos convencido de
que somos gemelos si decimos el
cumpleaños también sí y si nuestro
cumpleaños es el vecino
si
nosotras somos del primero ya tenemos 18
nacimos el 24 de julio
julia se equivocaron con su cumpleaños
quedé impactada es un poco raro que sean
gemelas y no sepan exactamente el
cumpleaños de la otra somos del 21 21 de
abril suponía que naciéramos el 20 pero
ese es el cumpleaños de nuestra mamá
literalmente dijo no compartir en mi
cumpleaños con otras dos personas
tenemos 21
como fue ir a la escuela fueron a la
misma si pero estábamos separadas fuimos
a la misma escuela primaria y preescolar
hasta
aproximadamente
y
la misma secundaria y vamos a diferentes
universidades éramos la única amiga de
la otra no hablábamos con nadie éramos
como las gemelas extrañas de resplandor
[Risas]
sospechaba de loren y kid simplemente
porque tenían una gran presencia
escénica eran las que más hablaban y
podría haber sido todo muy bien ensayado
de hecho nacimos en el cairo egipto
fuimos a la primaria y secundaria allí y
luego fuimos a una escuela secundaria
aquí fue un concepto entero el hecho de
tener a alguien que pasó exactamente por
lo mismo no creo que ningún amigo u otro
hermano pueda tener mi misma experiencia
me pregunto si la experiencia es
diferente para un niño y ni desear
amiguitos del mí sí es cierto ustedes se
cuentan todo entre sí sí
es gracioso porque habrá algunas cosas
de chicas que normalmente un chico no
conocería pero por supuesto
es gracioso si no puedo decidirme por
nadie
en el distrito
note que tienen ojos diferentes podrían
ser mejores amigas que dijeron lo
hicimos igual somos prácticamente
gemelas lo hicimos igual somos
prácticamente gemelas
definitivamente son familia pero también
podrían no ser
gemelos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
adiós chicas por favor levanten la mano
si aún tienen dudas y quieren seguir
jugando en 3 2 1
es muy pronto
una pregunta para todos siento que
alguien que no tiene un gemelo pensaría
que la relación entre gemelos es
increíble así que quiero preguntarles
cuál es la parte que menos es sagrada
para nosotras siento que lo peor es la
comparación la comparación así es lo
peor especialmente porque somos
idénticas al crecer cuando comienzan a
verse un poco diferentes dicen
tener a todo el mundo mirándote
constantemente diciendo ustedes se ven
diferentes por esto o aquello también se
vuelve muy molesto con respecto a
nuestras personalidades solíamos
parecernos mucho apesta porque entiendo
lo que dices ya que ahora sentimos que
nos vemos lo suficientemente diferentes
una vez un niño de séptimo grado se me
acercó y me dijo que la diferencia entre
tú y tu hermana tú eres la gemela más
corta escogen las peores partes de ti y
la señalan no le hacen eso a la gente
normal pero lo dicen porque sienten que
tienes un caso de estudio y de ende es
cierto nosotras cuatro somos gemelas
edades es decir ustedes la gente nunca
nos creía cuando decíamos que éramos
gemelas sentí que todos los pares de
mellizos tenían una dinámica muy
diferente a la nuestra no todos somos
iguales la operación se vuelve muy
agotadora al crecer peleábamos mucho
como dijiste hay mucha diferencia entre
nosotros especialmente cuando éramos más
jóvenes pero a medida que crecimos hemos
madurado y no peleamos por tonterías así
que sigo en cuantos minutos de
diferencia nació el 10 sí
deberíamos ir al centro y decir algo
bueno uno del otro
angie eres la atleta más talentosa que
conozco estoy muy emocionado de que
viajes al otro lado del país y continúes
este otoño en la universidad no atletas
de primera división chicos en lindo me
inspiras todos los días con tu gran
corazón y tu espíritu extrovertido
porque ahora estás en el teatro y sé lo
difícil que es para un chico a veces te
amo
eso fue interesante porque porque estaba
tan preparado ahora son una opción
porque antes no dudé de ellos eres mi
mejor amiga innata incluso si perdiera
todos mis amigos podría
podría contar siempre contigo yo también
te amo sé que las cosas han sido
difíciles en casa pero agradezco tenerte
ahí para enviar
bien porque iluminas cada habitación en
la que entras eres una luz brillante que
hace que todos se sientan cómodos e
importantes eres como mi conejillo de
indias puedo averiguar lo que me gusta
porque eres lo suficientemente valiente
para hacerlo primero te amo amigo
cuando nos mudamos aquí me sentía
extremadamente nostálgico pero estuviste
allí y me comprendiste cada vez que
estoy enojado entiendes el por qué
incluso a veces cuando nuestros padres
no lo entienden esto es lastimando a mí
no quiero decir que eres mi mejor amigo
porque eres más que eso no lo sé puedo
darte un abrazo
el viajar es la persona más trabajadora
que conozco me inspira sin emotivas
todos los días realmente admiro tu
humildad tu confianza tu impulso para
triunfar y sé que no importa lo que
suceda lo harás increíble eres mi todo
mi todos gracias te amo oh dios mío no
sé qué hacer
eso lo complicó
sé que se llaman amiga pero yo no
llamaría a mi hermano amigo promovido
llamaría así a algún amigo no muy
cercano tal vez
no hablaron mucho pensé que eran tímidos
pero creo que su conversación no fue tan
profunda como la de los demás
[Música]
chicas
levanten la mano si aún tienen dudas de
quiénes son los impostores y quieren
seguir jugando en 3 2 1
creí que ya habíamos descartado así los
descarte todos en las dos primeras
rondas eso es lo complicado mejor
prevenir que lamentar no seguir jugando
podríamos jugar otra ronda y si no son
los impostores no tienen nada que temer
sí exacto es mejor prevenir que lamentar
siento que potencialmente podrían ser
ellos pienso que todo lo que hicimos
solidificó el hecho de que es muy
probable de que ya los hayamos atrapado
creo que una más para estar seguros si
algo realmente profundo que solo los
gemelos sabrían si de acuerdo bien sí sí
estoy lista tengo mis sospechas estoy
segura de que nosotros somos gemelos
pero sin resentimiento siento que
ustedes podrían ser simplemente hermanos
jerry y rápidamente y rápidamente en qué
año se graduarán
2018 12 de enero del 2000
bien
que quería ser el de adulto no creo que
siempre haya sido así no creo que
siempre haya querido ser dentista eso
fue algo reciente pero nos graduamos en
lo mismo lo cual la ideología es entre
año porque a mí me atemoriza intentar
algo él siempre me ayuda a probar cosas
nuevas siempre lo hacen cuáles son las
preguntas sobre gemelos más molestas que
les han hecho
dónde está tu gemelo porque tu gemelo no
va contigo el gimnasio si tiene razón no
quiero decir que sea estúpido solo que
no tiene ni idea de lo que significa ser
gemelos en realidad si voy a hacer esto
si sé que hemos hablado mucho y no
tenemos mucho tiempo pero diría que
sospecho mucho de ellos y hoy cuando
hecho un poco de hoy creo que
simplemente tal vez sean primos y su
discurso fue un poco más como de amigos
muy cercanos
potencialmente hermanos y la cuestión es
que todos tenemos la misma dinámica de
género por lo cual es distinto entiendo
porque ya sabes chico y chica pero
también tenemos intereses diferentes
algo que sí han notado distinto entre
ustedes y nosotros es que todos somos
como terminamos las brazos de los ojos
todos
somos igual si michael y peter seguían
sacando a relucir los clichés sobre ser
gemelos en lugar de las cosas que deben
saber por ser gemelos todos los demás
eran gemelos idénticos y obviamente
nosotros somos mellizos nos quería que
nos sacaran por eso
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ya lo esperaban claro lo sabíamos pero
teníamos
y dijimos está bien si sospechan de
nuestro ser es gemelo es muy difícil
hacer eso por favor levanten la mano si
quieren seguir jugando en 3 2 1
vaya si alguien más se desnuda
yo si la luz se pone verde significa que
han eliminado a los impostores y han
ganado si la luz se pone roja significa
que ellos aún están en la caja y pierden
espero que hayan tomado las decisiones
correctas si perdemos el dinero me voy a
molestar tanto
[Risas]
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en cuanto a los países árabes
los gemelos falsos por favor den un paso
adelante y muestren se en
cuándo
dios
en su cumpleaños si somos hermanos pero
tenemos un año de diferencia
yo sí tengo un gemelo
[Risas]